السؤال المتداول اليوم دائما وعبر السنوات
هل المال يصنع السعاده جوابنا السؤال هذا
لا ماذا لو عدلنا خلينا قليلا في السؤال
هل المال يجلب الذكاء هذا سؤال اخر مجموعه
من علماء جامعه ليفربول وكليه لندن
للاقتصاد مشاهدينا يرون ان الاثريات
الاثرياء قد يكونون اكثر ذكاء من غيرهم
وثرواتهم قد تساعدهم على اكتساب الخبرات
المعرفيه ببساطه يقول اصحاب هذا التوجه ان
الغني بامكانيات الماديه قادر على تلقي
مستوى تعليمي واكاديمي مرتفع وبالتالي
ذكاء
الخبراء يعتقدون ايضا ان البيئه لها علاقه
بتنميه القدرات العقليه يعني باختصار
التواجد مع الناجحين يجعل منك على الاغلب
انسانا ناجحا ولكن اليست ذكاء مرتبط
بالجينات وبالوراثه وليس يعني بالضروره
بتحصيل العلمي يعني قبل ما نوصل اصلا
مرحله التعليم
افادك الله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات